repeal and replace is dead probably
because it had Obamacare
once again the tyranny of socialized
medicine prevails so as much as I don't
like admitting defeat the battle to
strip away Obamacare is officially over
it pains me to say this on our fourth
episode but ladies and gentlemen the
fight is finished
we've lost we'll be right back
are they gone
chuckle we good bring it in bring it in
fast fast fast too close too close
little back little back good good there
the fight over Obamacare isn't over no
quiet why yes we didn't lose the battle
is going on as we speak those people who
believe me when I said we were going to
commercial they're not smart like you
you are ready for the real truth this is
a covert transmission only you can know
about this is just between us
and just between us underground forces
are at work right now to free America
from the chains of this oppressive
healthcare once and for all
the narrative of the mainstream media is
that repeal and replace is dead that
Trump is out of luck but Trump is like
me he's a straight white guy we sweat
luck look at that just won five bucks on
a scratch off the real Obamacare repeal
is still happening and it's happening in
the same way that I watched every
episode of Pretty Little Liars in secret
and over a span of eight months and
that's also just between us now you've
heard of skinny repeal but this is
sneaky repeal it all starts with
undermining enrollment you see Obama's
plan only works if people fall for his
trap and enroll especially young healthy
sexy people I love that show and Trump
knows you can't enroll if you don't know
about it Trump administration is
slashing funding designated to get more
people to sign up for Obamacare
advertising to promote enrollment under
the Affordable Care Act will be cut from
one hundred million dollars to ten
million Trump made a 90 percent cut
that's one hell of a breast but the cuts
don't stop right there the number of
workers who guide consumers through the
enrollment process will be reduced by 40
percent these so-called guides are
supposed to lend a so-called hand to
so-called people who need so-called help
we don't want health care to be easy
then everyone gets it and then it's not
special don't shed a tear for those
unemployed helpers Obamacare is a dying
industry now they're free to get a
better job in a coal mine or a whaling
boat
but sneaky repeal is a multi-pronged
assault the Trump administration is
getting backlash for its plans to shut
down the Obamacare website during the
enrollment season officials say the site
will be closed for 12 hours on all but
one Sunday during the enrollment and
rightfully so sunday is the Lord's Day
you shouldn't be signing up for health
insurance you should be in church
praying you stay healthy the Trump
administration is also scaling back on
the enrollment period itself cutting it
from 45 days down from 90 days blank and
you miss it
just like my cameo is a dead clown on
Law & Order so fewer ads fewer guides on
a website that's about as functional as
Mitch McConnell's human suit but the
sneakiest way to defeat Obamacare is to
make sure people can't afford it in the
first place
the current Trump administration has
repeatedly threatened to stop the
payments and as a result individual
market premiums keep going up the image
I think of is somebody was stepping on
the oxygen hose of a patient and then
saying oh look the poor patient is dying
I mean it's because you're stepping on
the oxygen hosts easy drama queen Trump
isn't stepping on a patient's oxygen
hose
he's empowering that patient to breathe
on his own terms so let the Liberals
celebrate this so-called victory and
spray kombucha all over their unisex
locker rooms you and I you and I will
keep listening to Donald Trump
who has been hinting at this plan all
along Obamacare is it a total death
spiral let obamacare fail totally
implode collapse very bad shape
Obamacare is dead dead I could listen to
him say that all day long
literally we have that much footage so
don't worry fellow resistors the fight
isn't over it's continuing and we're
winning but we know what this
information getting out specifically
this information
don't screenshot these details are
posted online
remember this is just between us